during an oval office meeting with the
emir of qatar president trump was asked
about the role of labor secretary alex
acosta in the case of jeffrey epstein
back when mr acosta was a u.s attorney
in florida
house speaker nancy pelosi and senate
minority leader chuck schumer are
calling for secretary acosta's
resignation
thank you very much it's a great honor
to be with the emir of qatar a highly
respected man a real leader
in a large part of the world and a very
important part of the world
and we've known each other a long time
we've been friends for a long time and
we're doing a lot of work now they're
investing very heavily in our country
they're creating a lot of jobs they're
buying tremendous amounts of military
equipment including planes and they're
buying
commercial planes as you know very large
numbers of commercial planes from boeing
and we very much appreciate it we're
going to be signing a document today a
very large transit transaction you're
going to be invited to the signing
it's a transaction that will be
purchasing a lot of boeing jets and a
lot of money spent in our country and
that means a lot of jobs
so we just appreciate everything we have
a great
operation military operation right now
in qatar
they built one of the great military
bases i would say anywhere in the world
and it's just been
expanded with runways and everything
else it's been really uh a great honor
to work with my friend thank you very
much for being here thank you thank you
thank you
mr president i'm very happy and honored
to be here and thank you very much for
your hospitality as you mentioned we
enjoy a very great relationship between
qatar and the united states of america
we are doing a lot together as you
mentioned president we're signing a few
documents today and we our
economic partnership has been more than
185 billion and we're planning to double
this number we have a lot of investments
in the us we trust the economy here we
do a lot in the infrastructure and we're
planning to do more investment
yes we host
a date base and it's we're working very
closely together you're invited to come
and see qatar and also to visit the base
at any time mr president and i really
enjoyed the personal friendship with you
thank you very much thank you very much
and i will say
the base is incredible it's
what they've done there is absolutely
and a great place to have it
right in the middle of the middle east
and so it's a obviously it's a very
important location
uh so thank you all very much yes
president do you have any reaction to
the subpoenas the new subpoenas on jared
kushner and other members of your
administration i don't know anything
about it about iran how long are you
going to wait before you see the iranian
enrichment we're going to see what
happens with iran iran is doing a lot of
bad things right now and they better be
very careful
well you know i i met secretary acosta
this first time i know
when i
made the deal to bring him on into the
administration i can tell you that for
two and a half years he's been
just an excellent secretary of labor
he's done a fantastic job now part of it
is
our economy is so good our
unemployment numbers are at record lows
you know so many good things are
happening but the fact is he's been a
very good secretary of labor
what happened 12 or 15 years ago with
respect to when he was a u.s attorney i
think in miami is it miami
uh
you know
if you go back and look at everybody
else's decisions whether it's a u.s
attorney or an assistant u.s attorney or
a judge you go back 12 or 15 years ago
or 20 years ago to look at their past
decisions i would think you'd probably
find that they would wish they maybe did
it a different way
i do hear that there were a lot of
people involved in that decision not
just him i can only say this from
what i know
and what i do know is that he's been a
great
really great secretary of labor
the rest of it we'll have to look at
we'll have to look at it very carefully
but you're talking about a long time ago
and again it was a decision made i think
not by him but by a lot of people
so we're going to look at it very
carefully we'll be looking at that very
carefully okay
okay anybody else
well i knew him like everybody in palm
beach knew him i mean people in palm
beach knew him he was a fixture in palm
beach
uh i had a falling out with him a long
time ago i don't think i've spoken to
him for 15 years i wasn't a fan i was
not yeah a long time ago i'd say maybe
15 years
i was not a fan of his that i can tell
you i was not a fan of his so
i feel very badly actually for secretary
acosta because
i've known him as being somebody that
worked so hard and has done such a good
job i feel very badly
about that whole situation but we're
going to be looking at that and looking
at it very closely we're also going to
be signing a big contract in a little
while so we're going to see you in a
little while
in
a different room in a different part of
the white house where we're going to be
signing up a big deal with boeing
thank you very much we'll see in a
couple of
minutes thank you very
there has been discussion about an
appearance before congress